Welcome back.
I'm now going to do a bit of a
review of everything we've
learned so far about maybe even
trigonometry and
trig identities.
And then we'll see if we can
come up with-- maybe use what
we already know to come up with
a couple more trig identities.
So we know that from
SOH-CAH-TOA we know that sine
of theta is equal to the
opposite over the hypotenuse.
Let me draw a triangle here.
If I were to draw a
triangle here-- whoops.
Oh, there you go.
OK, so this is theta.
This is the opposite.
This is the adjacent.
This is hypotenuse.
Then sine of theta is equal
to opposite over hypotenuse.
Cosine of theta-- this is basic
review, hopefully at this
point-- is the adjacent
over the hypotenuse.
The tangent of theta is equal
to the opposite over the
adjacent, which is also equal
to the sine of theta over
the cosine of theta.
And we showed this in a
couple of videos ago.
And then, these are kind of
almost definitional, but the
cosecant of theta is equal
to the hypotenuse over the
opposite, which is the same
thing as 1 over sine of theta.
You can just memorize this.
I mean, I kind of find is
silly that there is such
a thing as cosecant.
I guess it's just for
convenience because you know
everyone knows it's just
1 over sine of theta.
And same thing for secant.
Secant of theta-- it's
really for convenience.
Instead of having to say, in
the case of secant-- oh, that's
1 you know-- if you end up with
the equation 1 over cosine of
theta you can just say,
oh, that's just the
secant of theta.
I think it actually has some
obvious properties and if you
were to draw unit circle
and all of that too.
But anyway, so that's equal
to the hypotenuse over the
adjacent, which is equal to
1 over cosine of theta.
And then, of course, cotangent
of theta is equal to the
adjacent over the opposite,
which is equal to
1 over tan theta.
And of course, that's
also equal to cosine of
theta over sine theta.
It's just the opposite of
the tangent of theta.
Or that's the same
thing as what?
That's the same thing as
the secant-- no, no, no.
It's the same thing as the
cosecant-- no, no no.
Let me make sure I
get this right.
It's the same thing as the-- I
just want to get the inverses.
Well, let's prove
what it is actually.
I always confuse myself.
So this is the same thing as 1
over the secant of theta over
1 over the cosecant of theta.
Secant of theta,
cosecant theta.
And then that equals the
cosecant of theta over
the secant of theta.
I wouldn't waste your
time memorizing.
So we know that a cotangent
of theta is equal to
1 over tangent theta.
Is equal to the cosine
over the sine.
And it also equals the
cosecant over the secant.
And I wouldn't worry about
really memorizing this.
You could derive
it if you had to.
As you could tell, I
really didn't have
this memorized either.
And we also learned in previous
videos that the sine squared
theta plus the cosine squared
of theta is equal to 1.
And that just comes from
the pythagorean theorem.
And if you play around with
this a little bit you'd also
get that the tangent squared
theta plus 1 is equal to
the secant squared theta.
You actually go from here to
here if you just divide both
sides of this equation
by cosine squared.
So we know that.
And then if you've watched the
last two proof videos I made,
we also know that the sine of--
let's say a plus b-- is equal
to the sine of a times
the cosine of b.
Plus-- let me erase some
of this because I don't
think that that is an
important trig identity.
You can derive it on your own.
I just wanted to show you that
you could figure it out.
I'm using too much space.
OK, now I have space.
Let me find that blue color
I was using and make
sure my pen is small.
OK.
So it's the sine of a times
the cosine of b plus the sine
of b times the cosine of a.
And you might want to
just memorize it.
This actually becomes really
useful when you actually start
doing calculus because you have
to solve derivatives and
integrals that you might
have to know the identity.
And it's not that
hard to memorize.
It's the sine of one of them
times the cosine of one of them
plus the other way around.
That's all this is.
And then we also learned that
the cosine of a plus b-- it's
the cosine of both of them
minus the sine of both them.
So that is equal to the cosine
of a times the cosine of b.
And I proved this in another
video, hopefully did it
to your satisfaction.
Minus the sine of a
times the sine of b.
These are pretty useful because
from these can we can come up
with a bunch of other
trig identities.
For example, what
is the sine of 2a?
Well, that's just the same
thing as the sine of a plus a.
And if we use this trig
identity up here, that is equal
to sine of a cosine of a plus
the sine of a, cosine of a.
I just used this sine of a plus
b identity up here and well,
want a and b are both a.
Now what does this equal?
Well, this is two terms
that are just both sine
of a, cosine of a.
So that just equals 2
sine of a, cosine of a.
So we now have derived another
trigonometric identity that
might be in the inside cover of
your trig, or actually,
your calculus book.
All of these actually,
I could draw a square
around all of them.
Let's do another one.
Once you have a bit of a
library of trig identities you
can really just keep playing
around and seeing what else you
can-- and I encourage
you to do so.
And you'd be amazed how
many other trig identities
you could come up with.
For example, let's
do cosine of 2a.
Cosine of 2a is equal
to cosine of a plus a.
And cosine of a plus
a, what did we say?
It's the cosine of both of the
terms times each other minus
the sine of both of the terms.
So that equals cosine of
a, cosine of a, right?
Cosine of a times cosine of a
minus sine of a, sine of a.
This identity was the cosine
of a plus b identity.
Minus sine of a.
So what is this?
This is equal to cosine squared
a minus sine squared a.
That's interesting.
We could play around.
This is interesting because
this is the form a
squared minus b squared.
So that's also the same thing
as a plus b times a minus b.
So that's the same thing as
cosine of a plus sine of a
times cosine of a
minus sine of a.
I don't know.
This isn't really a trig
identity, but I'm just showing
you could play with things.
Cosine of 2a is equal to cosine
of a plus sine of a times
cosine of a minus sine of a.
So the sum of the cosine
and sine of a then
times the difference.
That's just interesting.
I'm just showing you that
what's fun about trigonometry
is you can kind of keep
playing around with it.
And actually, that's probably--
that is how all of the trig
identities were discovered.
So let's say that we have-- we
want to figure out what cosine
of let's say, negative a is.
Well, let me draw
a right triangle.
Whoops.
That's almost a right triangle.
Now let's say this angle is a.
So negative a, unit circle
would look something
like this, right?
Negative a.
So cosine of a, if we say that
this side is the adjacent
side, this is the hypotenuse.
This would still be the
hypotenuse, right?
And this is the opposite.
This is the negative opposite.
So cosine of minus a
is equal to what?
This is minus a, so it's the
adjacent over the hypotenuse.
So it equals the adjacent
over the hypotenuse,
which we just say is h.
But that's the same thing
as cosine of a, right?
Because cosine of a is also the
adjacent over the hypotenuse.
Oh, I'm almost out of time.
Let me switch to a new video.